well a drone strike has hit the city of
naoa in southern Lebanon about 20 kilm
North of the border with Israel a
vehicle was destroyed in the attack
Israel has launched strikes in the past
to Target armed groups and journalists
in southern Lebanon since its war on
Gaza began in
October Z has more for us from
Beirut a Hezbollah military commander
has been killed and another member of
the group wounded in what appears to be
an Israeli drone strike now this is not
the first attack of its kind we've seen
a series of targeted assassinations
since Hezbollah joined the battle
against Israel to help relieve pressure
on its Ally Hamas in Gaza but this is
the first time uh a drone strike is
carried out in a major urban center the
city of nabati uh population center now
the men managed to get out of the
vehicle after the first strike but were
hurt in the second strike and the
commander subsequently died uh from his
wounds now no doubt this is an
escalation but it's not the first attack
of its kind Hezbollah and the Israeli
Army have been exchanging fire across
the border for some time now um the
conflict has been largely confined to a
few kilometers uh deaths on each side of
the Border um Hezbollah has been
targeting Israeli military positions
bases soldiers on the Israeli side while
the Israeli Army has been T targeting
what it calls H Bella's infrastructure
and CES in southern Lebanon um Western
diplomats have been visiting Beirut to
try to help uh calm tensions but
Hezbollah has made it clear the front
will not um Qui be there will be no
quiet along this front unless there is a
ceasefire in Gaza what Israel is
demanding is that Hezbollah pulls back
from the border it wants security
guarantees for tens of thousands of
people to return to Northern Israel but
Hezbollah will not give them uh those
guarantees until the war on Gaza ends
Zak Al jaaz Beirut